alors moi j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
d'interviews yvan attal vous disiez
toujours oui mais alors vous n'y
couperez pas on va faire une interview
oui mais alors je vous demande
simplement maintenir la phrase j'adore
ce film et mais je l'adorent un point tu
peux même pas imaginer
je suis peut-être pas le meilleur
réalisateur du monde mais mais au moins
dans mon film j'ai des meilleurs acteurs
du monde
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais d'autres non plus d'ailleurs
vous avez quoi laura et là je suis né
comme ça
ah bon je peux accéder je vous dis la
vérité je vous aviez une boucle
d'oreille quelqu'un vous l'avez je suis
très très en forme je raconte tout un
baratin comme quoi il y avait une femme
et qu'on a devant mais là je suis né
comme ça je le dis la vérité quoi vous
faire chez jeu plaît beaucoup aux femmes
mais où est le problème c'est vrai je
vais beaucoup aux jeunes mais je suis
marié je suis une star chez guillemets
mais vient pas d'eux mêmes et je
n'apprécie pas spécialement les
partouzes mai mais c'est parce que je
suis très jaloux et là dans leurs autres
j'aime pas les sandwichs grecs mais dans
une partouze
je suis pour la paix dans le monde mais
pas gagné bien à temps voilà c'est vrai
mais a gagné 3 mai mais j'ai peur mais
toujours j'ai peur de mourir mais ça je
me soigne j'ai envie de vous tu as aimé
mais un peu trop de man se marier avec
un chaman emmanuelle seigner sortie le
25 août
en tous les cas bravo super film
deadpool chez toi les oignons les trop
jeunes